i
[Música]
o sea confirmado las primeras
infecciones por la variante delta del
colón a virus dentro de sus fronteras
sucede días después de que los medios de
comunicación ya hiciesen sonar la alarma
sobre la presencia de esta nueva cepa
que es potencialmente más peligrosa que
las anteriores
rusia ha empezado la semana con 24.000
nuevos casos de coronavirus en un solo
día es el tercer número más alto de
infecciones diarias desde principios de
enero el país lucha contra la variante
delta que sigue en aumento y mientras
tanto alemania anuncia que va a cerrar
sus fronteras a los turistas rusos a
partir de esta semana precisamente para
evitar la llegada de nuevas cepas el
ministro de salud de rusia ha dicho que
en estos momentos hay más de 150.000
rusos que se encuentran hospitalizados y
muchos de ellos por culpa de esta nueva
variante en un país que tiene 140
millones de habitantes así que por si
acaso moscú está preparándose para
ofrecer una tercera inyección de la
vacuna para las personas que se pusieron
el segundo pinchazo hace más de seis
meses
[Música]
se cree que para finales de julio
francia estaría ante una cuarta ola de
contagios de coronavirus esto debido a
la rápida propagación de la variante
delta en todo el país con una tasa de
incidencia que ha venido en aumento
mientras que el ritmo de vacunación ha
disminuido por eso el gobierno está
buscando en maneras de incentivar a los
franceses para que vayan a vacunarse
estos pueden hacerlo a partir de los 12
años de edad y a la vez que todo esto
ocurre cada vez más voces por parte de
la de los médicos piden que sea
obligatoria la vacuna para el personal
sanitario esto en aras de preservar la
vida de los más vulnerables una idea que
por ahora el gobierno ha descartado sin
embargo los expertos afirman que para
detener la epidemia se necesita que el
85 por ciento de la población esté
vacunado por ahora se cree que para
finales de agosto en francia la mitad de
su población unas 35 millones de
personas estarán completamente vacunadas
[Música]
preocupa el gobierno en la propagación
de la variante delta en portugal que
representa el 70% de los casos de
contagio de kobe 19 que se han
registrado en las últimas semanas el
coordinador del plan de vacunación en el
país ha dicho que las próximas dos
semanas son cruciales y ha llamado a
acelerar el proceso de vacunación
aumentando el horario en los centros e
incorporando a los jóvenes entre 18 y 29
años para que sean vacunados la meta es
de 120.000 personas diariamente
portugal registrado y un índice de
contagio de ccoo y 19 de 231 por cada
100.000 habitantes y la cifra podría
aumentar en las próximas semanas el
gobierno también ha tomado nuevas
medidas restrictivas en los municipios
con mayor índice de contagio como lo son
confinamiento entre las 11 de la noche y
las 5 de la madrugada y prohibición de
salir de entrada del área metropolitana
de lisboa los fines de semana
[Música]